[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance as we hit the 100 day
benchmark of the trump presidency
unquote let's review his accomplishments
not accomplishments by our standards not
by human standards just why the stuff he
promised to do for those greedy hateful
and/or naive people who voted for him
let's list all that he's done for them
[Music]
yep in the first hundred days he's got
nothing done for them with the
Republican House and Republican Senate
and a Russian election in the first
hundred days he's gotten nothing done
with the great nationwide worldwide
liberating effects of the populist wave
to throw the baby out with the bathwater
in the first hundred days he's gotten
nothing done with one television network
dedicated to deliberately falsify in
reality to make it fit his addled mind
as he sits in a bathrobe watching it
with other networks wasting live
coverage on his public speeches his
garbled nonsensical stream of
semi-consciousness
as if they were actually news in the
first hundred days he's gotten nothing
done this truth utter impotence is of
course his greatest fear
he confessed it on Twitter last Friday
no matter how much I accomplished during
the ridiculous standard of the first
hundred days and it has been a lot
including Supreme Court media will kill
you do not need to be a psychoanalyst to
decode the sense of failure in that
though it helps to remember the context
of that phrase the ridiculous standard
of the first hundred days who set the
ridiculous standard of the first hundred
days he did here is candidate Trump's
contract with the American voter his
quote 100 day action plan to make
America great again contract his word
just sign here like you were enrolling
in Trump University there's lots of wall
were these stuff on the first page
column one ends with third I will direct
the Secretary of the Treasury to label
China a currency manipulator quote why
would I call China a currency
manipulator when they are working with
us on the North Korea problem well
because you put it in the contract that
you would in the first hundred days tick
tick tick tick tick tick tick by the way
for the uninformed you have just gotten
a taste of doing business with Trump but
it's in the contract
so sue me the second column ends with
suspend immigration from terror prone
regions we're vetting can't safely
occurred yeah how is that going for you
Sparky what's funny is the thing he
boasted about in that desperate tweet it
has been a lot including
court media will kill the SC part of
course was the confirmation of course
hitch to the Supreme Court
well how a Republican president got a
Republican Senate to reprove a
Republican nominee because the
Republican majority leader is such a
craven turtle that he destroyed two
pillars of the democracy getting that
new nominee confirmed that isn't even in
the Trump contract begin the process of
selecting a replacement for Justice
Scalia as I said there are some good
laughs on the front page of yet another
worthless Trump contract about all the
things he guaranteed he would do during
his ridiculous standard of the first
hundred days that he's just outright
failed at but it's the back page where
the fun really begins here's all the
legislation he was going to at minimum
get introduced into Congress a bill to
create 25 million new jobs nope a bill
to punish sending jobs out of the
country nope a bill to spend a trillion
dollars on infrastructure nope a bill to
give parents total choice on schooling
even religious schooling presumably at
government expense nope a bill to repeal
Obamacare and how's that going for you
Sparky why when I think of him
threatening to defund Obamacare unless
Democrats support the border wall why do
I get an image of Cleavon little in
blazing Saddles holding the gun to his
own head and saying hold it
the next man that makes a move the
moving on a child care and elder care
act that hasn't been written a bill to
fund that wall that reportedly not one
congressman or senator from the states
where the wall would be as said he will
support an anti-gang bill a bill
preventing international cyber attack
yeah kind of swing and a Miss right
there and lastly the clean up corruption
in Washington act enacts new ethics
reforms to drain the swamp and reduce
the corrupting influence of special
interests on our politics presumably
that was to be commemorated by a series
of Ivanka Trump's signature brand drain
the swamp formalwear and accessories
manufactured in China and available
exclusively at the spa by Ivanka Trump
at Trump old post office hotel for
wayward diplomats Washington DC 200 for
he's gotten
thing done and remember nobody nobody
said to him you have to do this in the
first hundred days or you will be a
failure he said that so what do you do
in the homework has to be handed in in
the morning and you haven't even found
your textbooks yet you claimed there was
no such homework
I think the hundred days is you know
it's an artificial barrier he said it's
not very meaningful he said somebody
yeah somebody put out the concept of a
hundred day plan you put it out to
somebody with the concept of 100-day
plan was you
that's your name [ __ ] right there [ __ ]
TR UMP [ __ ] so what do you do then when
you're denial that there was homework
also fails utterly well you claim the
teacher got the due date wrong the
hundred days is just an artificial
barrier the press keeps talking about
the hundred days I've only been working
on the health care you know I had to get
a little grounding right health care
started after thirty days so I've been
working on health care for sixty days
we're very close
ah see that's it this isn't really a
hundred days this is only sixty days who
are you gonna believe me or your relying
calendar if ever you needed additional
confirmation that this man's brain does
not work right there it is at the 100
day mark that was so important to him
that he wrote up a phony contract
predicated on it he is such a failure
that he is blaming the hundred days on
the media and actually claiming that it
isn't really a hundred days anyway no
matter how much I accomplished during
the ridiculous standard of the first
hundred days and it has been a lot
including SC media will kill his
greatest fear so let's help him
celebrate the hundred day mark he
doesn't desperately search Twitter for
compliments as much as he used to but it
is clear he still does it once in a
while let's flood it with tweets now
congratulating him on having completely
failed at everything in the first
hundred days including even counting two
hundred days let's have him figuratively
wading knee-deep in tweets at the White
House and don't forget since he claims
this is not really a hundred days but
only sixty we get to flood
again and congratulate him on even more
failure on the hundred day marking
alternate facts land which I calculate
to be Thursday June 8th mark your
calendars unless by then he's ordered
that we change all the calendars which
would make that date Trump day the third
of Trump member resist peace